if you're like me and you hate
installing stuff especially during the
winter months you're gonna absolutely
love this fully wireless security camera
sent to us from our sponsor nurio and
this thing comes with a totally unique
feature that I've never seen on any
other security camera system and that is
zero tool installation yes zero no tools
at all and in this video I'm going to
explain how it works and not only that
but I'm going to talk about the app
which I found to be surprisingly
reliable including the feature set and
the overall package so with that said
this review is going to go through a
couple of different things it's going to
start with the installation and the
setup then it's going to get into how
the app works and then my conclusion and
thoughts on it so let's get started now
I kid you not the installation was a
breeze the easiest thing I have ever
done but before I get into that I've got
a mentioned that norio is doing a
giveaway campaign so check out the link
below to enter now getting started with
what's in the box we have the globe like
norio camera which looks really cool and
it's packed with a bunch of sensors and
around the back you'll see that it has a
mounting hole for one of the mounts it
also has this weather sealed USBC port
for charging which it gets up to six
months of battery life which is a lot
and it has a USBC cable included and
you'll also see that it has a weather
sealed setup button and a couple of
speaker holes now as far as the mounting
systems you actually get two different
mounts in the Box one is traditional
which comes with a nice little ball
joint so you can position the camera any
way you'd like you simply take the two
pieces apart like this and in the box
you'll see it has an included mounting
sticker so just stick it wherever you'd
like drill a couple holes screw it in
then there you go you can mount it
traditionally now the second Mount is
where it gets very interesting and
unique yes it's magnetic as you can see
the camera magnetically attaches with an
incredibly powerful magnet and it's
awesome because there's a very wide
angle of adjustment that you can do and
the magnet still holds on so well making
it very easy to make micro adjustments
now this Mount can also be fastened to a
surface using the traditional method
with some screws and it locks into place
the same way however there's the
extremely unique zero tool method of
installation if you have a magnetic
surface that works for you simply just
plop it on and then put the camera right
on the mounts bam you are done but they
also include a 3M sticker that holds on
very well you simply stick it on the
back of the magnetic Mount then stick
that onto any flat surface apply some
pressure and there you go it also holds
on extremely well then simply place the
camera onto the mount and voila zero
tool installation complete in literally
just seconds I've never seen a more
convenient installation before and that
is actually the method that I went with
and it's still holding on just fine even
in the freezing winter cold it was
literally 15 degrees last night now the
awesome thing about the magnetic Mount
is that you could easily take it off to
charge it and you can actually use both
the traditional and magnetic Mount and
switch between different locations if
you want to and it actually allowed me
to do the installation before I actually
set up the camera with the app so let's
get into how easy that was to set it up
I just downloaded the norio app made a
free account and then added the camera
by simply scanning the QR code on the
back and then connecting it to my Wi-Fi
and Bam that was basically it super easy
to set up so with that said let me
actually go into the app itself and show
you how it works check this out this is
the main page we have the camera which
is set up as my front door you just tap
on it there you go it's loading up and
as you can see it's November and we have
snow everywhere you can simply just zoom
in move it around look at that this is a
live preview you can see the time stamps
right there it works very very well you
could even jump into this widescreen
view there you go look at that wide
screen and man the picture quality is
very sharp this is actually 2K quality
you can zoom in and clearly see people's
faces if you need to that right there is
awesome now what's really cool is that
you could actually hit this call button
right here and you could actually talk
to people outside let me try to turn on
the volume yep I can hear background
noise out there if there was somebody
out there
I'd be able to hear them so you can see
I can literally talk to people if they
come up warn them tell them to leave
there's a mute button right here so you
can turn on the speaker and hear what's
going on here's an alarm check this out
[Music]
yep the alarm is going off I should
probably turn it off before it gets too
annoying
okay there you go I turned it off so it
works quite well and there's also This
little light button because it comes
with a built-in light LED light that
works actually very well and at night
you can turn this on and switch from the
night vision mode which works very well
into the full color mode the really cool
thing is you can go back into time and
you can see this is when we were leaving
in our car that's my wife putting our
kids into the car and you can just keep
going I mean this is a really really
cool app oh that's when I was setting it
up
that's awesome and then just click that
button to go back to live there you go
very Snappy and responsive as you can
see we have the settings button right
there go in we have the motion detection
you can change the sensitivity you can
change and add activity zones which is
really cool if you want to avoid the
street if you have some false triggers
but surprisingly the notifications have
been spot on and only triggering when
there is somebody there so I'm really
impressed by the default settings we
have the video settings you can change
the video mode for night vision
Watermark you can rotate it if you have
it flipped here you can change your
notifications which you can add a rich
notification with a snapshot thumbnail I
definitely want to have that on change
your power management so it uses less
battery you can see we're at 77 percent
still so much more to go you have your
privacy security recording the audio
privacy zones if you want to block
something off and of course you have the
storage which is going to slowly fill up
up it has actually 16 gigs which it's
barely used any but you can easily and
quickly clear it to reset it if nothing
happened and then back to the home page
you actually have these different modes
you can switch to and you could actually
have it be location based so when you
come home it'll switch to the home mode
and then when you leave it'll be turn to
away so that way if somebody comes it
can trigger the alarm and scare somebody
off but when you're home you can choose
to make it not do that or maybe at night
you can have it go off and there's also
this security tab to adjust and
customize all of those modes including
the Geo fencing for location tracking
and you can even turn on automation if
you have multiple cameras set up so
overall I'm very surprised by the
reliability of this app so with all that
said if you combine the zero tool
installation with the really unique
magnetic Mount as well as the very easy
app setup and the reliability the whole
package together I really recommend this
camera it works so well very easy
installation the notifications work spot
on every time no issues at all I'm very
impressed with the norio wireless
security camera so that's my take
hopefully you enjoyed this video and
don't forget that they're doing a
giveaway campaign so use the link below
and they have direct purchase links to
Amazon Down Below in the description and
pinned comment as well so hopefully you
enjoy this video and if you did click
the circle above to subscribe check out
one of those two videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
foreign
[Music]